[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us at five
concerned tonight after many of you
called us saying you did not receive
your
additional six hundred dollars of
unemployment this week good news
the state unemployment office says it is
coming thank you for joining us at five
i'm brian loftis hi denise
hi there brian and i'm denise valdez so
the office admits it had an issue but it
should be fixed by tomorrow
with payments coming shortly after but
no specific date just yet
8 news now reporter kate houston
explains why that payment
could be the last one kate yes denise
bryan
federal pandemic unemployment
compensation gives claimants additional
money
on top of other unemployment benefits
which usually average between 300 to 400
dollars a month
now fpuc was authorized through the
cares act ending this friday july 31st
but last week deters said this funding
would end on july 25th
this could be due to the way the state
unemployment calendar is laid out
i reached out to dieter to confirm this
but they have not gotten back to me yet
i spoke to irene dama today who has been
relying on fpuc in addition to her other
benefits
she wants congress to extend these funds
i just hope the government
doesn't just drop it because
people are hurting maybe not give 600
but even 400 a month
an extra four hundred dollars a week
would help a lot of people
last week deters said it's in
communication with the department of
labor the governor's office
and federal delegates meanwhile in
washington d.c senate republicans
unveiled their coronavirus relief plan
called the heels act
it would cut the additional unemployment
benefits from 600 dollars
to 200 dollars democrats are hoping to
extend that current amount